JEFF BUCHAN: Good afternoon,
and welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Hello to everyone
watching on YouTube.
My name is Jeff Buchan, and I
work on the Industry Relations
team here at Google.
Extremely excited
today to be joined
by Pat Helding, owner and
creator of one of New York
City's most beloved
bakeries, Fat Witch Bakery,
which is right here
in Chelsea Market.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
Wow.
JEFF BUCHAN: Pat launched
Fat Witch in 1998,
and has since appeared on the
Food Network, CBS, CNN, MTV,
and her mouth-watering
brownies have been named
one of Oprah's favorite things.
On the heels of the success
of her first cookbook,
"Fat Witch Brownies,"
"Fat Witch Bake Sale,"
which you see up
there, includes 67
never-before-published recipes
for cakes, cookies, bars,
brownies, and more from
Pat's personal collection.
Pat and I actually
used to work together
in the days of Google
Offers, and I'm
thrilled to be speaking
with her again today.
So please join me in
welcoming Pat Helding.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
JEFF BUCHAN: So welcome, Pat.
JEFF BUCHAN: Thanks
so much for coming in.
It's great to see you.
PATRICIA HELDING:
It's my pleasure.
JEFF BUCHAN: I want to
start off by asking you
a few questions
about your background
and how Fat Witch came to be.
You made a pretty interesting
and probably uncommon
transition going
from Wall Street
to opening your own bakery.
So what made you want to leave
finance in the first place
and open your own business,
and then why a bakery?
PATRICIA HELDING: Good question.
Normally when I'm asked
this question, Jeff,
I usually give a
very upbeat answer.
This time, with Google,
I'm going to tell you
the down and dirty truth.
JEFF BUCHAN: We get
the real answer.
I like that.
PATRICIA HELDING:
The real answer.
I was a trader on Wall
Street, one of the first women
to be a specialist
on equity options.
Loved it, but I have to
say, trading finances
is not the most
satisfying thing.
It can be exciting, but it's
not the most satisfying.
I did recognize a certain
bubble in the market,
and I set up all the positions
for it and made a lot of money
for the firm.
And when that
money, those profits
were distributed
among all the traders,
I decided I was going
to run my own business.
And that's when I
started Fat Witch.
Why a bakery?
I had a great brownie recipe,
and I put one and one together
and said, this is
what I'm going to do.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's great.
So in opening and operating
your own business,
what would you say has been
the single largest challenge
in making that happen?
For those of us interested
in potentially opening
our own business one day.
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
I think the hardest
thing is to get started.
You've got to really believe
this is what you want to do.
What I've seen with
people who want
to open their own business,
they do a ton of research
or they just plunge ahead.
And you've got to get
somewhere in between.
So I think that's the
advice I would give anybody.
JEFF BUCHAN: Gotcha.
Were you always a good cook?
Is it something that
you did before you
started to do it for a living?
Was it something you
always had a knack for?
PATRICIA HELDING: Yes.
I like to cook.
I will admit it.
Yes, I like to cook.
I like to bake.
Always have.
My plan B, if the brownie
business didn't work out,
I was going to be a chef on
a yacht in the Caribbean.
No, I'm so glad it
didn't work out,
because I can't take the sun.
It was a comfort.
But I don't know
what I was thinking.
It gave me comfort.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's great.
Well, I ask the question
coming from someone
who is the opposite.
I'm probably the worst
cook in the world.
So that's where I'm coming from.
PATRICIA HELDING: You?
JEFF BUCHAN: Yes.
Pretty bad.
One thing I'm really
interested in personally
is how was the Fat
Witch brand born?
Such a cool logo and brand.
Where did the idea come from?
PATRICIA HELDING: I became
fascinated with branding.
Since we had no marketing
budget, no money whatsoever,
I did the logo myself.
Somewhere I got the
original drawing,
but it's been vectored out
in all sorts of things since.
Instead of reading cookbooks,
I was reading branding books.
I probably read 100 or so.
I would say my inspiration is
Starbucks and Howard Schultz.
JEFF BUCHAN: Really?
PATRICIA HELDING:
Well, you, think about
it-- a cup of coffee and
what they've done with that.
So that was my
inspiration to start it.
And branding is much
more complicated
than one would think at Google.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's great.
I consider myself a
dessert enthusiast.
And I can honestly
say that Fat Witch
brownies are my favorite
brownies in New York City.
You guys have had a lot
of success over the years.
Was there a certain
tipping point
that you can identify where you
thought the bakery has really
taken off?
PATRICIA HELDING: That's
a hard question to answer.
Very good question, but
it's pretty hard to answer.
Because it was
really slow at first.
And now you see Chelsea
Market bustling and hustling,
but it was not always that way.
One Sunday, we did
$43 worth of business.
That was pretty scary.
Now when-- I'd say probably
a number of years ago,
we started, oh my goodness,
we did twice as much
as we did a year ago on
that particular date.
And now when I see things revert
back to maybe two years ago,
I'm in the panic.
So I can't really
say what success is.
I don't know.
JEFF BUCHAN: It's
a moving target.
PATRICIA HELDING: Yeah.
Perfect, yes.
JEFF BUCHAN: Your store is
located conveniently close
the Google office in Chelsea
Market, which we certainly
love.
What has it meant to you
to be part of the Chelsea
community, and more specifically
the Chelsea Market community,
for so many years now?
PATRICIA HELDING: I'm going
to answer that question
by talking about Google.
Because we used to bake across
the street in Chelsea Market.
And basically, we would sell
all day and bake all night.
And Google was on
the second floor.
We were on the first floor.
And one day, this woman
came in, and she said,
I'd like you to come
upstairs with me.
And so I did.
It was my first time at Google.
And we went to this brick wall,
and it reeked of chocolate.
It was just so strong.
It was unbelievable.
It was almost like the bakery.
So that was a great moment
at Google, and I thank you.
And I don't know whether
it's still there,
because we no longer
bake in Chelsea Market.
We have expanded
facilities uptown.
But it's been a great
relationship ever since.
JEFF BUCHAN: And so do you feel
a large sense of camaraderie
with the other businesses
in Chelsea Market?
Because you guys have been
there for a long time now.
Not always the case in
the other locations.
Do you coordinate a lot with
the other business owners
and things like that,
or is it just everyone
running their own
separate shops?
PATRICIA HELDING: It's
pretty much everyone
is running their own shop.
I think the management really
coordinates things over there.
So we try to be good neighbors.
We let the flower shop
come in and use our water
and take gallons of water out.
But it's really management that
does most of that coordination.
JEFF BUCHAN: Gotcha.
Any plans to expand with any
additional Fat Witch locations
potentially?
PATRICIA HELDING: We
would love to expand.
We have a financial
hurdle to get over,
and then we hope to open
up more stores in New York
pretty rapidly.
JEFF BUCHAN: Gotcha.
Very cool.
One thing the last time we spoke
that I found very interesting
is that you mentioned Fat Witch
has a very large following
in Japan, which I found
surprising and really
interesting.
Any plans to do more
there, potentially open up
a shop overseas in Japan?
PATRICIA HELDING:
Thank you for asking.
I just got back
from Japan, and we
hope to partner-- the
final agreement has not
been done-- but we hope to
partner with a butter factory
and bakery in Japan.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
And the reason we have so many
Japanese customers from Japan
is that in Japan, they
have a culture of cute.
And you have to
think of Hello Kitty.
Even their UPS
transportation company,
their logo is a kitten
holding a baby kitten.
So it's called kawaii.
If you've been to Japan, you'll
see lots of kawaii around.
And I think the first
five years or so, I
pictured there were
lots of brownies
sitting at people's bookshelves
just for kawaii sake.
And I've never eaten,
but I think we're
getting people to eat them now.
Because chocolate is
new to Asia, by the way.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's interesting.
That's probably
one of those things
that you could never
have anticipated
when you started your business.
But interesting to see
how Japanese clientele
is a really big thing for you.
PATRICIA HELDING: It is big.
And we target some things
for that clientele.
The candy that we do, those
little two-inch cube boxes,
that is targeted for Japanese
from Japan so they can take
omiyage back to Japan as a gift.
JEFF BUCHAN: Very cool.
I know from working
with you in the past
that you are very tech forward.
I'm saying that seriously.
When you have your own
business and you're
everything from the
CEO to the head cook,
it's not easy to make
time for new technology
and experimenting,
but I think you
do a really good job with that.
Can you talk a little
bit about the role
that technology and
the internet has
had in growing your business?
PATRICIA HELDING: I
think if you don't
have any technology
in your business,
you really don't
have a business.
I'm just laughing because I
feel we're so behind the times.
And then you just told me
earlier that other people
that you work with
are really behind.
I thought, oh my goodness.
I can't believe that
we were-- we want
to get much more tech forward.
I always get good ideas from
Google and participating
in some of your
seminars and things.
I have a vision of a production
room that's got computers,
and you just type in the
recipe that you're going to do,
and it comes up with visuals
of how to do it as well
as a lot of stuff in the store.
So we'd like to be much more.
JEFF BUCHAN: When you are
baking, how much of it
is a measured science versus
just an art where you're still
experimenting?
Is it very calculated where
everything is the same,
or is it more experimentation,
trying new things?
PATRICIA HELDING: Baking is
more scientific than cooking.
You can mess around
with a marinara sauce
far more than you
can a brownie recipe.
Once you get the recipe set, it
is done by pounds and ounces.
We don't take two
eggs and break them.
It's eight pounds of eggs,
because we're doing 80 quarts
at a time.
So it has to be measured.
That doesn't mean we don't
experiment with recipes.
I always believe I've never
seen a recipe I can't change.
But once it's set,
particularly being commercial,
we have to make that
the same way each time.
JEFF BUCHAN: And
coming from finance,
I'm sure you're familiar with
the idea of economies of scale.
It seems like baking
is a lot about that,
estimating demand
and things like that.
Is that difficult to do?
I would assume that demand
swings from day to day and week
to week.
How do you go about the process
of estimating how many brownies
are we going to sell today,
how many do we need to produce?
PATRICIA HELDING: That
is such a good question.
Now I'm going to have to
tell you another secret.
JEFF BUCHAN: Uh oh.
Don't tell.
Nobody tell.
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
This is how we do it.
We bake, we let it cool
down, we cut the brownies,
we wrap the brownies,
they go in the freezer,
and it's stacked up.
So we pull out what
we need for the day.
You've never known
that those don't
come directly out of the oven.
The unwrapped ones
that we have do.
That we juggle, and we run
out of stuff all the time.
Because you're so right.
JEFF BUCHAN: It's tough.
PATRICIA HELDING: It's
tough thing to call.
And one day, everybody
wants the vegan brownies,
and the next day
it's the coffee one.
It's very hard.
But that's the way we do it.
Even for Japan-- we're
there twice a year
for food shows-- we
have it flash frozen,
it gets picked up by a
truck, in a frozen truck,
goes to the dock in New Jersey,
still frozen, down the Atlantic
Ocean, across the Panama Canal,
across the Pacific Ocean.
It takes four weeks.
I've met it in Yokohama.
They're fine.
You would never know.
We flash freeze everything
is the real truth.
JEFF BUCHAN: Gotcha.
I gotcha.
What is the fan
favorite in the bakery,
and what is your favorite?
PATRICIA HELDING: I
would say probably
the caramel witch is the fan--
didn't see people over there,
sorry-- the fan favorite.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's
my favorite, too.
PATRICIA HELDING: Is it?
JEFF BUCHAN: It is.
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
Good to know.
For me, I like whatever
we've just produced.
The red velvet witch,
or we just did a witch
with lavender extract in it.
I'm pretty unfaithful.
JEFF BUCHAN: Your
first cookbook,
which came out in 2010,
you published the recipe
for your famous brownies.
Was that a hard
decision to publish
that in a book for
everyone to see, something
you struggled with, or
was that an obvious thing
you knew you wanted to do?
PATRICIA HELDING:
In a word, Jeff, no.
It wasn't a problem.
I think running a
business is-- the hook
is running the business.
My recipe-- with research, you
could duplicate a Fat Witch.
When I was in Japan
in the butter factory,
they said, oh, we've made it.
We don't need your recipe.
Because they can take it apart.
Now, are you going
to do that at home?
No.
Are you going to build a
business out of brownies?
Probably not.
So the answer is no.
It wasn't.
JEFF BUCHAN: It's
more about just
the brownies at this point.
It's about the Fat Witch
brand and all the stuff
that surrounds the brownies.
PATRICIA HELDING: Yeah.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's great.
So now I'd like to
shift gears a little bit
to talk about your
second cookbook, which
we have right here.
We also have these available
to purchase afterwards
if you guys are interested,
which I highly recommend.
What was the impetus
for this cookbook?
Obviously, it was a different
focus than the first one.
Where did the idea for
this cookbook come from?
PATRICIA HELDING: The idea
came from my agent, which
I can't believe I'm say I have
a literary agent, but I do.
When she said you've got
to do another cookbook,
I said, Sharon, huh?
What?
And I said, I told
you everything
I know about baking,
about brownies.
That was cookbook number one.
And she said, do you
still bake at home?
And I said, yeah, I do.
And she said, go through that.
So she came up with the
idea of "Bake Sale."
And it's really my
stuff that I do at home.
But we threw in lots of stuff.
JEFF BUCHAN: A lot of
non-brownie items in there.
PATRICIA HELDING: Yeah.
We've got cake in there.
It's the best chocolate cake
you're ever going to make.
JEFF BUCHAN: What are some basic
ingredients that you recommend
that people have on
hand just in case
their children forget the
morning bake sale at the school
or something like that, they
have to prepare something
in a pinch.
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
JEFF BUCHAN: Any must haves
that people should just always
have on hand?
PATRICIA HELDING:
Don't write this down.
Instead of making
specifics, I'm going
to give you five elements
that are good to have at home
if you're ever going to bake.
And you can make
a lot of things.
The first is you have to have
something sweet if you're
going to do a piece of pastry.
And sweet doesn't have to
be white granulated sugar.
It can be honey.
It can be agave, which I hear
is your new sweet of choice
here at Google.
Wow.
Brown rice syrup,
maple syrup can work.
There's a lot of
things you can do.
The next thing you
would need would be fat.
And it doesn't
have to be butter.
It can be a butter substitute.
Earth Balance is a good one.
I don't use margarine, but
that's an oil base fat.
If you're vegan,
you probably already
have a jar of coconut oil,
which I've learned to love.
Amazing.
And I did take a note on this.
Canola oil.
And there's lots of
other oils out there.
You just have to
make sure-- olive oil
I never use for baking, because
it has too much of a flavor.
But canola is pretty neutral,
so you might want to do that.
So that's two.
Three would be eggs
or an egg substitute.
Four would be flour.
And flour is what binds
pastries together.
I always thought it was eggs,
but it actually is flour.
Who knew.
So it can be with
gluten or gluten free.
Just please make sure
if you use gluten free
it's not cup for
cup substitution.
You have to have a recipe
that's got gluten-free flour.
Let me rephrase-- that
was specifically written
for using gluten-free flour.
And the last thing you need,
Jeff, to put in your cupboard
is flavor.
And of course, we
love chocolate.
But it could be peanut butter,
strawberries, strawberry jam,
whatever your flavor is.
And you probably already
have things in your cupboard
that would work.
So it's not complicated.
But just think of
those five elements.
JEFF BUCHAN: That's
good to know.
So this book, I think, really
has something for everyone.
You break it down into
different categories--
things like gluten-free recipes,
foreign recipes, kids recipes,
et cetera.
Are the different areas
that you broke down
in the book-- are these areas
you're seeing a lot of demand
from customers and that's
how you got the idea
to break it down that way?
Or what were you thinking there?
PATRICIA HELDING:
Yes, I think there
is a lot of demand for
things like gluten free.
I put recipes in there,
and I do it at home
even though I keep flour on
the premises, gluten flour.
And please be careful
if you are a celiac
or have a problem with gluten.
Don't go to a bakery
that's got both.
Because once it's in the air,
I don't care how many times
you clean the equipment.
It's major to
become gluten free.
So if somebody says
they're gluten free
and then they've got bread
next to it, it's probably not.
But I think that's going
to get much stricter
with the government soon.
Vegan was new to me, and I
sort of turned up my nose,
but it's fantastic.
I love doing coconut oil.
And you don't need
eggs for everything.
JEFF BUCHAN: And you sell the
vegan brownies in your store
now, right?
PATRICIA HELDING: We do.
JEFF BUCHAN: They're
pretty popular?
PATRICIA HELDING: Yes.
People are tweeting,
I got the last one.
And I'm like, yay.
That's great.
JEFF BUCHAN: I am a very
amateur baker slash cook,
and I'd say that's pretty
generous to put it that way.
Are there any recipes in
this book that you recommend
that even I could take on?
PATRICIA HELDING: Most of
them you could take on.
JEFF BUCHAN: Really?
Even me?
PATRICIA HELDING: Oh yeah.
I promise you.
There's one that's a no bake.
You use rice crackers.
Just dribble chocolate
on top of it.
Fantastic.
It's called the
toffee crunch chunks.
Easy.
JEFF BUCHAN: So if I were
to pick up this book,
top three recommendations
for me, what would they be?
PATRICIA HELDING: I'd
do the toffee crunch.
I'd do vegan.
Very easy.
When I have a dinner
party, I never
remember to bring
home brownies-- never.
And I do the vegan.
You can just knock it
together like that.
And the third one, I don't know.
Just look for something
really simple.
I can't think of one
off the top of my head.
JEFF BUCHAN: I think there
were some cinnamon toast crunch
bars.
PATRICIA HELDING: Cinnamon
toast, that's great.
JEFF BUCHAN: Those
caught my eye.
I might try those.
PATRICIA HELDING:
That is really good.
You have to like cinnamon.
JEFF BUCHAN: I do.
I just don't like--
baking is the issue.
I'll let you know how it goes.
PATRICIA HELDING:
These are easy.
You'll get a test.
JEFF BUCHAN: Sounds good.
I want to make sure we
leave time for questions
from the audience.
So we have two
microphones there.
You guys have any questions,
feel free to step right up
and ask your question to Pat.
In the meantime, I'll go
with one more from me.
Any advice for people
who are looking
to start their own business?
We talked about the challenges.
But what would your advice
be if some people are just
starting to think
through that process
and think it's something
they might want to pursue.
PATRICIA HELDING: I think,
as I said before, it's good
do some research.
It's a lot easier to
do that research now
than it was 15, 20 years ago.
I think perhaps the
most important thing
would be to have the
finished project in mind.
What you want?
Do you want a store?
Do you want to
just do wholesale?
Do you want to consult
with this person?
Whatever.
Have that in mind, and
then you can backtrack
of what you need to get there.
And then once you
have that business
plan ready, be prepared
to change everything.
You're going to
have to shift gears,
because things are
going to change.
I didn't know the Japanese from
Japan were going to come in.
JEFF BUCHAN: Great.
That's great.
Question over there, Carly.
AUDIENCE: My question
actually builds on that.
How easy or hard is to start
a business in New York City?
You could have done this in
a lot of different cities.
It could have been
more challenging.
Or maybe because of the foot
traffic of where you chose,
Chelsea Market ended up being
a really smart decision.
Can you tell us a little
bit about New York
City versus another place?
And then also, why
Chelsea Market?
Because you mentioned
you were a trader,
and you obviously knew
downtown, even further downtown.
Why here?
What was the connection?
PATRICIA HELDING: Wow.
I think New York is
difficult, particularly
in the food business.
I will tell you that from
what I hear from inspectors
and also from people who deliver
our ingredients, we're cleaner,
believe it or not, than
a lot of other cities,
a lot of other places.
The inspection is tough,
and it's thorough.
So we can't have anything
on the floor, whatever.
So New York is tough.
It's probably the toughest
in the United States
in terms of food.
Rents are probably higher
than any other place
except for probably
Alaska and Hawaii.
But you get foot traffic here.
People are on their feet.
If you take Los Angeles, for
instance, people are in a car.
So I just thought, well,
I know New York better.
So that would be the reason.
And I live here.
Chelsea Market, when it first
opened, was inexpensive.
And they wanted people to come
in and produce food there.
So it is much,
much different now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PATRICIA HELDING: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So a follow up to
your business plan question.
I know there are certain things
you couldn't account for,
like your Japanese expansion.
But aside from that, when
you were doing your business
planning, did you make
a conscious effort,
like I'm going to
keep this small
and contained, or I
want global domination?
PATRICIA HELDING: Very good.
I don't think global
domination ever occurred to me,
but I wanted to be-- I wanted
to be the brownie that you
would go to.
I think that those are
really good elements
to put into your business plan.
And then depending on
how you get your funding,
that is going to affect that.
What is the finished
product going to look like?
We're nowhere near
our finished project.
We've got stores to
build and things to do.
I'm going to be back
in Japan in September
and maybe Dubai with partners.
So we're still a
work in progress.
But I think the more you can
put those elements in early on,
you're going to be shocked 10
years later at how much it's
changed.
But try to get them in.
You want to get your
demographics in,
you want to get who your
clients are going to be.
And this is part of branding.
You want to know what they buy.
Google, you guys
are great at that.
So there you are.
AUDIENCE: Do you do
demographic analysis constantly
just so that you understand
your changing client base?
PATRICIA HELDING: Not
on a professional level.
But it's really more a gut feel.
JEFF BUCHAN: So anecdotally,
when people come in the door.
PATRICIA HELDING: Yeah.
And that's why I'm
in the bakery a lot,
just to talk to people,
that kind of thing.
But I don't know.
I guess we've done some
surveys and things,
but it's hard to
get the whole reach.
For us, we're pretty tiny.
JEFF BUCHAN: Another
question over there.
AUDIENCE: I have two
questions if that's OK.
PATRICIA HELDING: Sure.
AUDIENCE: First, pretty
straightforward--
what is your process for
coming up with the new recipes?
Are you personally
coming up with all
these new
combinations, or do you
have a team of
helpers and tasters
and people with their ear to
the ground on new flavors?
PATRICIA HELDING: I have
a production manager,
and she knows far more
about baking than I do.
And this is also built
into my business plan,
that I knew I have no
training in baking.
I didn't know what a
commercial oven was.
But that's plunge
ahead and go do it.
So she knows much more.
Strangely enough-- she's a
graduate of Hyde Park Culinary
Institute, which is the
highest of the high in food
in the United States.
I'm the one with two cookbooks.
Go figure.
Life is strange that way.
But we collaborate, and then
we test on our employees
all the time.
And in the bakery,
too, sometimes.
JEFF BUCHAN: If you ever
need any extra testers,
you know where we are.
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
Good.
We'll bring it over.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have three questions.
I came up with another one.
I haven't looked at the
book yet, but I will.
You have all these
different variations.
And I'm just thinking that
"The New York Times" just did
a thing on what makes
a sandwich a sandwich.
At what point is a
brownie not a brownie?
What's a brownie
versus a cookie?
Is it the ingredients in it,
the shape, the squareness?
PATRICIA HELDING: They think
that brownies were invented
by somebody who forgot to
put baking powder or baking
soda into a cake.
And there's no written
history of this,
but they think that it
was like a fallen cake.
And it was in the
United States for sure.
That's the only thing we know.
And it is one of our few
American-based pastries, that
and chocolate chip cookies.
Because most of
our pastries here
are based on either German,
Austrian, or French,
and now some Japanese.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll let someone
else ask a question.
Thank you.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PATRICIA HELDING: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just sampled
your vegan brownie,
and it was delicious.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And I am not a vegan.
Question-- you were talking a
little bit about the marketing.
And I'm curious how you came
up with Fat Witch, the title
and the logo in general.
Why a witch?
PATRICIA HELDING: OK.
I like witches.
When I was a trader,
one of my friend traders
had a laugh just like
a-- she had a cackle.
It was just like a witch.
And I would bring brownies
to the trading floor.
And Pamela would
come over every day.
And I said, Pamela, seriously,
this is a lot of butter.
You're going to be a fat witch
if you keep eating these.
And I just thought
it was a funny name.
And as I said, I
just drew the logo,
because we didn't have any
money to hire a graphics person.
Now I have a graphics person.
But back then, no.
And one thing, some
people when we started out
said, that's a terrible name.
You should ever use that.
But nobody forgets it.
That's the trade off with it.
JEFF BUCHAN: I guess the
question is, does Pamela
know that she is the
inspiration for Fat Witch?
PATRICIA HELDING: Yes.
JEFF BUCHAN: She does?
PATRICIA HELDING: She does.
Good question.
JEFF BUCHAN: I
think we might have
time for one or two more
questions if anyone has them.
PATRICIA HELDING: Go ahead.
Sure, come on.
JEFF BUCHAN: Step right up.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you had dreams
of one day using technology,
and it could be all automated.
I guess my question is if
that could really happen
and you took that step, at
what point is it too far?
Would you go fully
automated if you could?
Is that still
baking, or does there
need to be some sort
of human element in it?
And do you lose
something of your brand
if it becomes too
automated in the process?
PATRICIA HELDING: That is
a genius question there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JEFF BUCHAN: Third
time is a charm.
PATRICIA HELDING:
A lot of baking
is pretty automated
with depositors
as they go along
a conveyor belt--
the dropping in so much flour,
dropping in so much stuff.
You've seen it on the
Food Network and stuff.
I don't think we're going to
ever be that globally dominate,
but we would do that.
What's nice about that is that
there aren't any mistakes.
But I think you
do lose something.
I can't pinpoint
what it would be,
but I think it makes
you less experimental.
I think a Hostess
cupcake is always going
to be that Hostess cupcake.
JEFF BUCHAN: All right.
Time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: We're like
the question people.
PATRICIA HELDING: All right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So we used to be based in
this building, my team,
and we just recently moved
over to Chelsea Market.
PATRICIA HELDING:
You used to be what?
AUDIENCE: We used to be
based in this building.
So we just moved over about a
month ago to Chelsea Market.
And it's the bane
of my existence,
because I'm walking
through bakery corridor
on my way to work every day.
So I have a huge sweet tooth.
My question for you-- if you
weren't eating at Fat Witch,
you've already had your
fill of Fat Witch-- what's
your next stop?
Which is your
favorite other bakery?
JEFF BUCHAN: Good question.
AUDIENCE: And what
would you get there?
PATRICIA HELDING: I would
probably go to Sarahbeth's.
I think she has
quality pastries.
I do like-- she's got
an egg salad sandwich,
and I think she makes the
English muffins or whatever,
the biscuits she puts it on.
Buying somebody else's brownies
I only do for experiment.
[LAUGHTER]
Cookies maybe.
But I would probably
go to Sarahbeth's next.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So then Ruthy's versus Eleni's,
do you have a preference?
PATRICIA HELDING: Ruthy's
isn't there anymore.
AUDIENCE: It's
not there anymore?
When did that happen?
PATRICIA HELDING:
A couple weeks ago.
Because they're going to
put something else in there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
JEFF BUCHAN: All right.
Well, Pat, thanks so much for
coming in and for bringing your
treats to us.
We're all very appreciative.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
JEFF BUCHAN: And good
luck with the cookbook.
It's wonderful.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
And there are lots of treats.
Please help yourself.
That's so many more.
JEFF BUCHAN: Yes.
We have treats and
cookbooks in the back, so
feel free to grab either.
PATRICIA HELDING: Take
more than one, please.
JEFF BUCHAN: Great.
Thank you.
PATRICIA HELDING: Thank you.
JEFF BUCHAN: Thanks, Pat.
[APPLAUSE]